und damit kommen wir dann jetzt auch zum
nächsten einzelplan da wird ein
ministerium
diskutiert dass es vorher noch gar nicht
so gab das bundesministerium für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen wurde erst
in dieser legislaturperiode
geschaffen ursprünglich vorher gab es ja
das bundesministerium des inneren für
bau und heimat und die ganzen aufgaben
zum boden zum bauwesen die sind jetzt
noch dazu gekommen
für dieses ministerium das konzentriert
sich nun eben auf wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
400.000 wohnungen möchte die neue
regierung pro jahr bauen
davon sollen 100.000 öffentlich
geförderte wohnungen seien also hier
wird auch auf den sozialen wohnungsbau
wert gelegt ob das klappen kann wie das
klappen kann darum wird es jetzt hier in
der aussprache gehen die zuständige
ministerin klara geywitz steht hier auch
schon bereit sie wird hier als erstes
zum einzelplan sprechen einzelplan
allerdings noch wird gewartete natürlich
müssen jetzt die entsprechenden
politikerinnen und politiker hier ihre
plätze einnehmen
und deswegen wartet
bundestags-vizepräsident
und so bedeckt und sollte diese daran
hindern seinen amtsgeschäften
nachzugehen zum beispiel beim
telefonieren mit der geschäftsführung
der fraktion bitte ich dann diese
gespräche einfach nach außerhalb des
plenums zu verlagern
ich öffne die debatte das wort hat die
bundesministerin klara geywitz sie ist
bundesministerin für ohne
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren abgeordnete es
ist ja an sich schon etwas besonderes
wenn die bundesregierung den entwurf des
bundeshaushaltes für dieses hohe haus
einbringt aber jetzt passiert noch mal
etwas ganz spezielles sie wissen es das
bundesbauministerium wurde wieder
gegründet am 8 dezember und es gibt
erstmals seit 1998 wieder dieses
wunderbaren ministerium das bedeutet
natürlich für unsere
haushaltsverhandlungen es gibt auch
einen funkelnagelneuen einzelplan 25 und
ich bin sehr sehr froh dass ich ihn
heute einbringen kann weil ich weiß dass
dieses dieser neugeborene einzelplan
dieses neugeborene bei ihnen in guten
händen ist bei den parlamentarischen
beratungen
denn wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauen
das sind themen die den alltag von ganz
ganz vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern in
unserem land berühren themen die täglich
am küchentisch diskutiert werden mit
freunden mit bekannten aber natürlich
auch zunehmend themen die mit fragen und
sorgen einhergehen deswegen ist es ein
schwerpunkt dieser bundesregierung dass
wir dafür sorgen sollen erstes dass es
ausreichend bezahlbaren aber auch gerade
klimagerechten wohnraum gibt wir sind
der überzeugung
wohnen es nicht nur ein menschenrecht
ist es auch unsere aufgabe als politik
dafür zu sorgen dass dieses recht auch
gelebt werden kann
wir haben uns vorgenommen die weichen so
zu stellen dass 400.000 wohnungen pro
jahr gebaut werden können und davon
100.000 bezahlbare öffentlich geförderte
sozialwohnungen ich bin mir bewusst dass
es ein großer kraftakt für den bund aber
natürlich auch für die länder diese
wohnung werden gebraucht gerade in
ballungsgebieten es geht besonders um
familien mit kinder für auszubildende
studierende für ältere um ganz
entscheidende fragen finde ich denn eine
bezahlbare wohnung in meiner nähe in
meinem kiez kann ich hier wohnen bleiben
wird meine miete steigen oder steigt sie
dem nicht an weil modernisiert wird
diese fragen sind richtig wichtig und
wir sind es die den bürgerinnen bürgern
eine antwort darauf geben müssen
diese fragen werden wir als politik
nicht alleine beantworten deswegen werde
ich im april ein bündnis für bezahlbaren
wohnraum staaten mit vertreterinnen und
vertretern der länder der bauwirtschaft
natürlich der mieter
interessenvertretung aber auch von
umweltorganisationen und mir war es auch
ganz wichtig jürgen dusel den
beauftragten der bundesregierung für die
belange von menschen behinderung mit in
dieses bündnis einzuladen weil ich sage
sozialer wohnraum der muss auch immer
inclusive sein
das entscheidende instrument für
bezahlbare wohnung bleibt der soziale
wohnungsbau
dafür brauchen wir geld dieser haushalt
und die finanzplanung liegen dafür eine
entscheidende grundlage die bundesmittel
für den sozialen wohnungsbau werden in
der finanzplanung auf insgesamt 14,5
milliarden euro deutlich erhöhten
dass man stehen allein zwei milliarden
in 2022 zur führung das ist jedenfalls
dass tragfähige fundament auf dem wir
den bau von 100.000 sozialwohnungen in
deutschland erreichen können
mein ziel ist es
mit den ländern konkrete vereinbarungen
zu treffen welche investoren sie im
bereich des sozialen wohnungsbaus
vornehmen auch und gerade für spezielle
zielgruppen wie studierende und azubis
oder projekte zur bekämpfung der
obdachlosigkeit denn das ist auch ein
großes ziel meines ministeriums
ich freue mich dass wir als in dieses
koalition gemeinsam davon überzeugt sind
dass wir 8,5 millionen euro mehr für den
sozialen wohnungsbau investieren als es
im vergleich zur vorgängerregierung der
fall war
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wie es dabei aber genauso wichtig dass
wir neben der bezahlbarkeit das thema
klimagerechtigkeit in den blick nehmen
die frage wie wir heute dafür sorgen
können unseren kindern und enkelkindern
eine intakte erde zu hinterlassen ist
eine der zentralen herausforderungen
dieser regierung ich werde oft gefragt
sind sie dafür sozialen kreiswerken
wohnungsbau zu bauen oder sind sie dafür
klimagerechten wohnungsbau zu bauen ich
sage beides muss zwingend zusammen gehen
wer billig baut der baut doppelt und wer
heute baut damit die menschen niedrige
mieten haben der kann ich so bauen dass
sie in zukunft hohe nebenkosten haben
nein gebrauchen beides sozialen wohnraum
der über 60
wir werden sehr viel anstrengungen
unternehmen müssen um auch im bereich
der energetischen sanierung besser zu
werden und noch hier die großen
potenziale des wohnungsbaus denn
gebäudewirtschaft für die co2 einsparung
zu heben hier sind wir zusammen mit dem
bundeswirtschafts- und klimaministerium
dabei die energetische sanierung in
deutschland anzukurbeln aber wir werden
auch die aufteilung der co2 kosten auf
mieter und vermieter so regeln dass es
einen anreiz gibt in den bestand zu
investieren die sanierung des bestandes
als eine große herausforderung
ein zweiter punkt der wichtig ist es die
frage wie gestalten sich unsere städte
gemeinden und quartiere hier sind wir
dabei weiter intensiv wie in den letzten
jahrzehnten über die bewährte
möglichkeit der städtebauförderung zu
investieren und setzen diese auf einem
hohen niveau mit 790 millionen euro pro
jahr fort wichtig ist
dass wir
unsere innenstädte rizzoli entmachtung
dass wir sie stärken dass wir sie zu
lebendigen zentren und ortslagen
entwickeln gerade nach kona werden wir
hier gemeinsame große anstrengungen
unternehmen müssten deswegen habe ich
zum beispiel ein beirat für die ihn
steht ins leben gerufen ich werde auf
eine außenstelle des
forschungsinstitutes in cottbus gründen
gerade um zb die ländlichen regionen
stärker zu erforschen und zu fördern es
bleibt viel zu tun wir haben einen
großen investitionsbedarf im bereich der
sozialen der kulturellen infrastruktur
aber auch zb der sozialen infrastruktur
deswegen freut mich freut es mich dass
ich das sf programm biwak auch weiter
finanzieren kann bis 2027
wir müssen schneller werden beim bauen
und beim planen auch das liegt auf
unserer agenda und nein es ist mir zum
schluss ganz wichtig dieser haushalt
zeigt dass mein haus ein investitions
ressort ist zum beispiel in deutschland
50 prozent aller jährlichen
investitionen bauinvestitionen und von
diesen sind 54 prozent im neubau und im
bestand dass die bauwirtschaft aber auch
die wohnungswirtschaft sie leisten einen
sprechen entscheidenden konjunkturellen
beitrag für die entwicklung der
wirtschaft in deutschland etwas worauf
wir angewiesen sind sie stehen
gleichzeitig vom großen herausforderung
in der transformation mein ministerium
will diesen transformationsprozess
begleiten denn ich bin der meinung
bauwirtschaft in deutschland hat zukunft
bauhandwerker zukunft herzlichen dank
leider wird es hier auch nicht nur auf
die investitionen verwiesen und auf die
zukunft die sie hier in der
bauwirtschaft natürlich auch sieht auf
sie direkt antworten
wird nun der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der größten
oppositionsfraktion erich lange von der
cdu csu im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
frau ministerin ist es tatsächlich etwas
besonderes wenn wir seit
1998 erstmals wieder eine echte bau
haushaltsdebatte führen in der wir dann
auch ausreichend zeit haben über die
themen bauen wohnen und stadtentwicklung
zu sprechen und man nicht ist jetzt mal
ganz ein annex zu anderen großen häusern
ist ob umwelt oder innen es begrüßen
auch wir sehr ich glaube ja sie haben es
damals abgeschafft bitte nicht vergessen
und zwölf jahre zusammen haben wir es
auch nicht wieder hingekriegt deswegen
dieses lob an alle die sich für die
politik gemeinsam einsetzen deswegen
freut mich diese debatte
ein eigenes ministerium alleine macht es
aber auch noch nicht es geht nicht nur
um ein türschild es geht nicht nur um
eine gebäudehülle sondern es geht ja
tatsächlich um die ganz große
gesellschaftliche aufgabe wohnen
stadtquartier
zusammenzuführen zusammenzudenken und
zusammen zu entwickeln und dafür braucht
man zum einen finanzen und zum anderen
handlungsfähigkeit und zu beiden themen
möchte ich ein paar sätze sagen ja
die ausstattung des haushaltes ist auf
den ersten blick
zumindest so dass man starten kann aber
eben auch nicht mehr wir freuen uns ganz
besonders über den aufwuchs beim
kindergeld das zeigt dass die idee der
letzten periode eine erfolgreiche war
uns fehlt im haushalt die antwort wie
eigentum in zukunft für junge familien
geschaffen werden soll da kann ich ihnen
nur die fortsetzung dieses baukindergeld
des frau ministerin
als erfolgsmodell empfehlen die
die dynamisierung des wohngeldes findet
sich in diesem haushalt auch
entsprechend wieder auch das war
angelegt die städtebauförderung
verstetigt ja aber eben auch nicht mehr
wenn wir jetzt aus der krise kommen aus
der pandemie heraus wo die fdp in vielen
punkten schon notleidend geworden sind
und jeder der so ein bisschen in der
kommunalpolitik unterwegs ist war es
dass der große aufgaben auf uns zukommen
und der beirat für innenstädte frau
ministerin der ist jetzt nicht neu
sondern den bericht des beirates kannten
wir ja auch schon aus der letzten
periode das entscheidende wird sein auch
tatsächliche konsequenzen daraus zu
ziehen und die mittel entsprechend
bereitzustellen das finden wir
allerdings in diesem haushalt noch nicht
insofern
insofern sind wir gespannt was er dort
an dieser stelle auf uns zukommen jetzt
komme ich zum zweiten punkt er ist
mindestens so wichtig dass die
handlungsfähigkeit
denn sie brauchen handlungsfähigkeit in
den entscheidenden feldern und die sehen
wir bei diesem neuen bauministerium
nicht sie sind entschuldigung wenn ich
das so sage ein bisschen königin ohne
land wo haben sie denn die wirkliche
kompetenz und federführung wenn es um
die themen baupreise geht rohstoffe
lieferengpässe wo um die fachkräfte wer
soll denn diese wohnungen bauen ohne die
fachkräfte sei es in heizungs sanitär in
klimatechnik und all den bereichen
bau kredite werden teurer
sie sitzen aber nicht mal im
aufsichtsrat der kfw das hat sich ja
jetzt schon mal als negativ
herausgestellt
die flächenknappheit bei der bima die
wie man ist auch im finanzministerium
geblieben ohne fläche kein baum frau
ministerin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der neuen regierung ein
bauministerium auf der zuschauertribüne
lösten nicht die herausforderungen die
wir in diesem bereich haben die
architektur dieses hauses ist um es mal
bautechnisch zusagen wacklig oder aber
es ist vom fundament nicht ordentlich
gegründet und deswegen haben wir schon
in der frühen phase gesehen wo der
architektonische fehler liegt nämlich
zum beispiel beim stopp der kfw
förderung für energieeffizientes bauen
genau dort wo junge familien klima
effizient ökologisch hochwertige bauen
wollten haben sie gesagt stopp hier an
dieser stelle nicht mit dieser regierung
welche riesenschaden welche riesa diesen
vertrauensverlust
sie haben dann ein bisschen ein
trostpflaster eingeführt aber die träume
der familien sind geplatzt jetzt wird
und der frau ministerin werden wir sie
messen im zweifel von diesen familien
eben nicht im energetischen standard
gebaut sondern billiger gebaut weil
genau diese förderung fehlt ja was ist
das denn bitte mehr klimaschutz nein es
ist weniger klimaschutz mehr lebens- und
wohnqualität nein es ist weniger lebens-
und wohnqualität und das kann doch nicht
die antwort eines neuen bauministerium
sein liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ja an dieser stelle große pläne aber
bisher noch relativ wenig dahinter
ambitioniert oder utopisch 1,6 millionen
wohnungen in dieser periode wo ist die
baukosten senkung kommission wo sind die
fachkräfte wo sind die flächen
und wo sind die perspektiven für
energieeffizientes bauen das sind die
antworten die wir von dieser regierung
erwarten arbeiten sie daran wir werden
sie daran messen die erwartungen sind
groß das was wir bisher gesehen haben
ist aber nicht mehr als eine ganz
einfache skizzen dankeschön
ulrich lange
kritisiert ist würde sich bei der
ministerin um eine königin ohne land
handeln unter anderem weil er seiner
meinung nach die kompetenzen fehlen die
zustimmung lag ein bündnis 90 und 150
nächster redner ist andreas autowracks
für bis 90 die grünen
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren nach einer langen pause ist das
heute hier eine premiere wir haben
haushaltsdebatten erlebt in den letzten
legislaturperioden in denen das thema
wohnen bauen stadtentwicklung immer
zusatzpunkt war zu anderen themen dass
es jetzt anders und das ist gut so weil
dieses thema eine ganz zentrale soziale
frage ist eine ganz zentrale ökologische
frage ist es richtig dass wir das so
machen frau ministerin geil wird sich
freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit und
auch die zusammenarbeit mit ihnen hier
im parlament
ich komme aus neukölln aus berlin aus
meinem wahlkreis und da erlebe ich aufs
bitterste was für eine schwierige und
harte soziale frage das thema bauen ist
ich habe mit vielen mieterinnen und
mietern in den letzten jahren darum
gekämpft dass sie nicht aus ihrer
wohnung fliegen ich weiß was es bedeutet
wenn sozial bindungen auslaufen ich habe
in der großsiedlung gropiusstadt für
energetische sanierung geworben und
immer wieder erfahren das ist eine
existenzielle frage für ganz viele
menschen und es ist zugleich eine
existenzielle frage für das überleben
unseres planeten und genau mit diesem
anspruch mit dieser größe des anspruches
sollten wir das thema angeben
ich möchte eine dimension zu diesen zwei
dimensionen ergänzen die klimafrage die
es wichtig die soziale frage ist eine
zentrale es kommt aber hinzu dass die
frage des bauens und des wohnens auch
eine frage der strategischen
souveränität des angesichts dessen was
wir in der ukraine erleben müssen wir
müssen investieren um den klimakollaps
zu verhindern wir müssen investieren um
die soziale frage des wohnens zu lösen
wir müssen aber auch investieren weil es
unerträglich ist dass so viele menschen
in deutschland abhängig von einem
diktator wladimir putin sind wenn es
darum geht ob ihre wohnung im winter
warm ist oder nicht da müssen wir raus
das müssen wir beenden die passieren wir
müssen raus aus den fossilen energien
wir müssen raus aus putins gas wir
müssen raus aus dieser existenziellen
abhängig genau abhängigkeit genau das
ist die aufgabe dieser zeit und genau
das steht jetzt an und genau das werden
wir finanziell in diesem haushalt
unterlegen
wir brauchen einen langen atem
in dieser frage aber wir müssen die
fragen die akut entstehen auch akut und
sofort lösen die steigenden
energiekosten die treffen menschen mit
kleinen einkommen hat in dieser zeit und
es ist nicht nur richtig dass wir den
heizkostenzuschuss auf den weg gebracht
haben es ist noch besser und noch viel
wichtiger dass wir ihn verdoppelt haben
das haben wir hier gemeinsam geschafft
270 euro heizkostenzuschuss dass es geld
das ganz direkt ankommt dass den
menschen ganz konkret hilft denn wir
sind uns einig und das ist gut und
richtig so in dieser koalition eine
warme wohnung muss garantiert sein eine
warme wohnung darf in diesem land für
niemandem zum luxus werden
genau diesen weg
genau diesen weg den setzen wir fort die
soziale frage und die klimafrage bringen
wir zusammen das wohngeld das muss
dauerhaft entlasten da hilft die
dynamisierung um aber alle haushalte
auch in der klimakrise dauerhaft
entlasten zu können müssen wir
weitergehen um die menschen auf die
frage der klimakrise vorzubereiten und
sie zu wappnen brauchen wir ein klima
wohngeld
wir müssen
auch beim bauen eine wende hin kriegen
und zwar eine soziale und ökologische
und herr lange so sitzen sie wenn sie
hier sagen dass das baukindergeld die
lösung dieser probleme sind dann sind
sie auf dem holzweg mit verlaub ich
verrate kein geheimnis wenn ich sage
dass das baukindergeld aus unserer sicht
völlig untauglich ist dadurch entstehen
nicht die bezahlbaren wohnungen die wir
brauchen damit lösen wir keine frage in
bezug auf die klimakrise die verteilung
von geld mit der gießkanne dass es das
was wir von ihnen gewohnt sind aber für
uns ist das keine zukunftsperspektive
wir müssen zu diesem programm stehen und
das muss auch finanziert werden so viel
verlässlichkeit ist nötig aber das was
wir tatsächlich heute starten müssen ist
eine wende in der politik eine völlig
neue phase der politik mit sozialen und
ökologischen aspekten und genau das
gehen wir ab jetzt in dieser koalition
an und
ich ergänze ich ergänze zur
energetischen ich ergänze zur
energetischen sanierung und da können
sie jetzt sich aufregen an der seite der
ganze einsatz dazu wenn sie von seiten
der cdu csu mit minister altmaier uns
diese ganzen probleme diesen müll vor
die füße kippen und sich dann hier
aufregen dann ist das unredlich wir
wollen mit in münchen
und beschert haben jetzt hier auch dass
es das was hier übernimmt und diese
verdrehung von tatsachen ist genau das
was für jeden parlament nicht brauchen
es ist gut dass die ampel für sozialen
wohnungsbau sorgt seit 1990 hat sich die
zahl der sozialwohnungen mehrheit mehr
als halbiert diesen trend die müssen wir
stoppen hunderttausend sozialwohnungen
jährlich das ist unser ehrgeiziges ziel
und weil wir nicht nur einen sozialen
aufbruch wollen weil wir auch einen
ökologischen aufbruch wollen machen wir
soziales und ökologisches klimaneutrales
wohnen und bauen zugleich wir
reservieren einen milliarden-betrag
explizit dafür für das soziale wohnen
und für das ökologische bauen das ist
der anspruch beides zusammen zu denken
und den erfüllt diese koalition
in diesem etat geht es um das bauen
aber und diese anmerkung sei mir auch
als berliner abgeordneter gestattet das
bauen ist nur die eine seite der
medaille um die wohnungsfrage zu lösen
müssen wir auch mieterinnen und mieter
im bestand schützen bei mir neukölln
kämpfen jetzt zur stunde menschen darum
weil sie angst haben dass ihnen ihre
wohnungen ihr haus von investoren
genommen wird jetzt werde im moment in
dem ein vorkaufsrecht genau das wäre was
die kommunen brauchen und aufgabe dieser
koalition und an der stelle ist es auch
aufgabe und anspruch an sie liebe frau
gallwitz ist dass wir an der stelle so
schnell wie möglich rechtssicherheit
schaffen das vorkaufsrecht brauchen die
kommunen das vorkaufsrecht müssen wir
wieder ermöglichen und genau dass es
aufgabe dieser koalition und werden wir
angehen
die ampel ist angetreten um in zukunft
zu investieren
und dazu gehört es den menschen ganz
direkt zu investieren aber auch in ihr
lebensumfeld und aus diesem grund werden
wir auch in das schwimmbad vor ort in
das lebensumfeld in die kommune
investieren weil es so wichtig ist für
menschen wenn sie vor ort sind dass ein
schwimmbad saniert ist und dass das
funktioniert dass wir parks haben dass
wir erholungsräume haben das alles
werden wir angehen deswegen werden wir
nachhaltig und seriös an der stelle
investieren ich danke ihnen für die
vorlage dieses etats und ich freue mich
auf die gemeinsame beratung vielen dank
andreas
den etat und die pläne verteidigt und
insbesondere dann doch die
vorgängerregierung kritisiert für dem
was vorher
gesagt ein mitglied des
haushaltsausschusses und mitglied der
fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren es ist das erste mal seit vielen
jahren dass der bereich wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauwesen in einem
eigenen ministerium und mit einem weiten
einzuplanen hier der haushaltswoche
behandelt wird und gleich die erste
amtshandlung des neuen ministeriums und
von ihnen frau ministerin war es sich 95
hoch dotierte stellen für den aufbau
ihrer
ministerialbürokratie
genehmigen zu lassen erster handlungen
sind ja auch immer erste hinweise für
die grobe richtung der politik und mit
mehr bürokratie wagen haben sie leider
das komplett falsche signal gesetzt da
frage ich mich doch wie im
innenministerium der bauen wohnbereich
in der letzten wahlperiode funktioniert
hat es erzählt uns hoffentlich niemand
dass horst seehofer die arbeit von 95
beamten alleine stemmen wollte eine
große herausforderung in unserer zeit
ist die situation auf dem wohnungsmarkt
besonders in den ballungsräumen neben
den horrenden strom und heizkosten
maßgeblich verursacht durch die politik
der regierung merkel und von links geld
jetzt fortgesetzt sind die mieten das
große problem viele haushalte in
deutschland zahlen hohe mieten und für
viele ist wohnen vor allem in
großstädten nahezu unbezahlbar geworden
die koalition versprach 400.000
wohnungen in deutschland jährlich bauen
zu wollen in ihrem haushaltsentwurf für
2022 finde ich dazu lediglich 750
millionen euro an die länder
zur stärkung des sozialen wohnungsbaus
mit 750 millionen euro forderungen
wollen sie also 100.000 neue
sozialwohnungen bauen bei den klammen
länder kassen und die restlichen 300.000
neuen wohnungen wir haben schon aus
kapazitätsgründen der bauwirtschaft
wunschvorstellungen bleiben links gelbe
versprechen die schon bei der
ankündigung zum scheitern verurteilt
sind
bauen ist in deutschland so teuer wie
nie baumaterial ist knapp und die preise
dafür sind drastisch gestiegen das
stellt gerade handwerksbetriebe bei der
abgabe von angeboten vor enorme
herausforderungen
ob ihr angebot im laufe des
baufortschritts überhaupt haltbar sein
wird nicht wenige betriebe bringt das in
existenzielle nöte und was machen die
regierungsparteien in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag sie satteln unter
unter dem stichwort klimaneutral auf die
kostenspirale obendrauf oder auf deutsch
noch teurer und unbezahlbar so sieht
ihre politik aus
diese politik führt dazu dass noch
weniger menschen sich die eigenen vier
wände arbeiten können oder durch
privaten wohnungsbau der mietmarkt
entlastet würde mit regelungswut das
klima verändert zu wollen wird vor allem
an den geldbeutel vieler wähler gehen
die sich ihre wohnungsumbau politik
nicht leisten können ich danke für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
für die fdp-fraktion hat nun der kollege
torsten herbst dass
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir neben eine premiere
wir debattieren erstmals über den etat
des neuen bauministeriums ich freue mich
auf diese debatte wären wir können als
koalition konkret gestalten und sie sind
als opposition eingeladen mitzuwirken
meine damen und herren wir
erleben einen neuen haushalt aber haben
gleichzeitig erblasten aus der alten
regierung speziell aus dem csu geführten
innenministerium und im bild zu bleiben
herr lange wir haben hier ein haus was
erhebliche statik fehler hat dafür
tragen sie die verantwortung wir werden
diese statik fehler reparieren
viel geld ist im programm gebunden die
wo die förderung nicht passgenau bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern ankommt wo
zusätzliche eigentumserwerb nicht
wirklich gefördert wird oder auch
modernen ausreichung mit erheblichem
aufwand und bürokratie verbunden ist in
einem beispiel haben sie selbst genannt
das war das baukindergeld
über 20 das heißt jeder fünfte euro des
etats fließt in ausgaben für das
baukindergeld und wenn wir ein 20
prozent für baukindergeld ausgeben
müssten wir eine bauoffensive erlebt
haben wie noch nie in diesem land aber
ich habe den eindruck es gibt viel
mitnahmeeffekt es gibt keinen wirklichen
effekt im sinne einer schaffung von
neuem wohnraum
wir werden die ab finanzierung
sicherstellen werden solche unsinnigen
programme nicht verlängern die cdu/csu
wir haben eine ganze reihe von
herausforderungen baubereich vor uns es
schon angesprochen wurden wir haben
wohnungsknappheit in hohe mieten in
ballungsräumen aber und das gehört auch
dazu wir haben leerstand und rückbau
bedarf in ländlichen regionen bekämpfen
mit der verfügbarkeit von arbeitskräften
von baumaterialien steigenden baukosten
und wir haben auch zu wenige
wohnungseigentümer und diesem land wir
tragen im eu-vergleich die rote laterne
das wollen wir ändern meine damen und
herren
wohnen ist nicht irgendein luxus wohnen
ist ein existenzielles bedürfnis und
deshalb wird es höchste zeit dass wir
die politik der realität anpassen im
interesse der mieter im interesse der
eigentümer im interesse der bauherren
meine damen tag
und deshalb sollten wir uns auch sehr
bewusst sein was unsere entscheidung für
eine wirkung haben meine damen und
herren wäre dass bauern verteuert
verteuert auch die mieten deshalb
sollten wir bei neuen technischen
anforderungen vorsichtig sein sie nicht
ins unermessliche steigern und mars und
mit erhalten damit nicht nur bauen
bezahlbar bleibt und auch wohnen
bezahlbar bleibt
viele träumen von den eigenen vier
wänden und ist ein traum den wir
unterstützen wollen denn egal ob man in
münster oder meisten wohnt wohneigentum
ist immer noch die beste altersvorsorge
und wir sollten den deutschen
wohnungsmarkt nicht ausschließlich durch
die brille der ballungsräume betrachten
denn in vielen ländlichen regionen haben
wir erheblichen leerstand und vielen
ostdeutschen landkreisen über zehn
prozent auch dort werden wir rückbauen
müssen entwickeln müssen damit dieser
region attraktiv bleiben
nicht alle können wollen den
ballungsräumen leben und deshalb ist es
genauso wichtig dass wir die ländlichen
regionen attraktiv gestalten dass wie
sie gut anbinden über straße über en v
dass wir schnelles internet in dieser
region bringen und dass wir gute
angebote für kultur bildung und sport
unterbreiten damit die lebensbedingungen
in ganz deutschland attraktiv sind als
koalition meine damen und herren wollen
wir dafür sorgen dass mehr gebaut wird
wir wollen dafür sorgen dass genehmigung
einfacher werden und dass sich mehr
menschen den traum von den eigenen vier
wänden erfüllen können
was wollen wir dafür tun es geht darum
dass wir mehr bauland und mehr flächen
ausweisen und es geht darum dass wir bei
kosten senken durch digitalisierung
standardisierung und entbürokratisierung
es geht darum stadtentwicklung und
stadtumbau voranzutreiben und wir wollen
zusätzliche anreize für den
eigentumserwerb schaffen das ist das was
wir uns als koalition gemeinsam
vorgenommen haben
und mehr wohnraum meine damen und herren
schaffen wir auch nicht durch bestimmte
maßnahmen die mietpreis deckel mehr
wohnraum schaffen wir dadurch dass wir
mehr und schneller bauen dem fühlen wir
uns verpflichtet
wir sind als grund nicht gemeinsam
unterwegs sondern wir brauchen länder
und kommunen auch wenn es beispielsweise
um die ausweisung von bauland geht auch
beim sozialen wohnungsbau wir haben den
willen die entschlossenheit und die
ideen die politik in diesem land auf
neue füße zu stellen ich freue mich
darauf ich wünsche uns eine erfolgreiche
debatte des baujahrs
torsten herbst hat hier auch noch einmal
verteidigt wie die koalition auf das
thema bauen schaut was sie da plant
natürlich kann der bund allerdings
auswärtige besucher schließen sie eine
wohnungstür auf gaben bereich der länder
victor perli spricht spricht jetzt für
die linke sprach er ist sprecher für
umverteilung
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren seit jahren explodieren
die mietpreise auch strom und heizung
werden immer teurer
bezahlbarer wohnraum ist in vielen
regionen mangelware es gibt immer
weniger sozialwohnungen inzwischen
fehlen fünf millionen das darf so nicht
weitergehen das muss sich eigentlich
ändern
die linke begrüßt deshalb dass es ein
neues ministerium für bauen und wohnen
gibt spd und grüne hatten ist und sind
98 abgeschafft es war ein fehler aber
sie haben jetzt die chance verpasst
dieses neue ministerium stark
aufzustellen es fehlt an politischem
willen und es fehlt auch an kompetenzen
das neue ministerium ist zahnlos es ist
für das mietrecht überhaupt nicht
zuständig das liegt weiter beim
justizministerium also ausgangs bei der
fdp im koalitionsvertrag
gibt es keine einzige neue maßnahme um
explodierende mietpreise zu stoppen
keine miete preisobergrenze keine
mieterhöhung stoppen angespannten
wohnlagen nichts von dem was spd und
grüne im wahlkampf versprochen hatten so
wird das nichts meine damen und herren
spd grüne und fdp setzen einseitig auf
das mantra bauen bauen bauen dabei
verschweigen sie dass neubau zu teuren
mieten führt und lange dauert den
letzten jahren sind die baupreise und
die bodenpreise massiv gestiegen wer
einseitig auf neubau setzt der löst die
probleme nicht wer bezahlbaren mieten
sichern will der muss wohnraum von
profitmaximierung schützen
das ergebnis sehen wir auch im haushalt
weil die mieten immer weiter steigen
müssen bund länder und kommunen auch
mehr geld für das wohngeld die kosten
der unterkunft bereitstellen mit
öffentlichem geld werden hier abhängen
die vermieter belohnt die immer höhere
miete verlangen deshalb fordert die
linke einen mieten deckel denn der ist
gut für die mieter und gut für die
steuerzahler für den
sozialen wohnungsbau soll den nächsten
jahren endlich mehr geld ausgegeben
werden aber es bleibt weit hinter dem
zurück was eigentlich notwendig wäre der
deutschen mieterbund
die stimme der mieterinnen und mieter
hat völlig recht die sagen die mittel
reichen nicht mal auf um die wohnungsbau
ziele aus dem koalitionsvertrag zu
erreichen das grundproblem bleibt
jährlich fall mehr sozialwohnungen aus
der bindung als neue entstehen der
soziale wohnungsbau der letzten
jahrzehnte ist heute die beute der
mieter um das zu ändern braucht es nicht
nur mehr geld wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass
wohnungen die mit öffentlichem geld
gefördert werden nicht mehr nach ein
paar jahren aus der preisbildung frei
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass
mieterinnen und mieter verdrängt werden
deshalb muss öffentliches geld für
dauerhaft öffentlich öffentlichen uns
dauerhaft bezahlbaren wohnraum sorgen
vielen dank
nächster redner in der debatte zum
einzel etat für das bundesministerium
für wohnen stadtentwicklung und bau
weshalb mir gut ich schwitze für die
spd-fraktion
[Applaus]
präsidentin sehr geehrte frau ministerin
neuen kolleginnen und kollegen
etwa alle vier tage schließt in
deutschland ein hallen- oder freibad
und zwar für immer
eine umfrage der deutschen lebens
rettungs gesellschaft hat ergeben dass
knapp 60 prozent der älteren
grundschulkinder nicht schwimmen können
ein kaputtes schwimmbad darf dafür nicht
der grund sein das muss sich ändern
fallen
diese weg dann fehlen auch die zentren
der gemeinschaft und des sozialen
zusammenhaltes wird dem bundesprogramm
sanierung kommunaler einrichtungen in
den bereichen sport jugend und kultur
greift der bund den kommunen helfend
unter die arme und unterstützt die
städte und gemeinden bei mehrheit ihrer
so wichtigen sozialen infrastruktur seit
2005 10 konnten 290 projekte bewilligt
und insgesamt 1,5 milliarden euro vom
bund gefördert werden
die projekte sind von besonderer
regionaler und überregionaler bedeutung
diese maßnahmen haben weitreichende
wirkung für den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt und die soziale integration
sie geben einen entscheidenden impuls
für die stadtentwicklungspolitik und den
klimaschutz
klimaneutral sanierte einrichtung stoßen
auch weniger emissionen aus
das programm ist eine erfolgsgeschichte
von nord bis süd in ost und west darum
ist es gut dass im haushaltsansatz
für das bundesprogramm erhebliche mittel
zur verfügung gestellt zur verfügung
stehen wir werden uns in den
haushaltsverhandlungen dafür weiter
stark machen und vielleicht geht er ja
noch ein bisschen mehr der kollege
autorin der kollege herbst haben zu eben
angedeutet jeder mensch hat das recht
auf angemessenen wohnraum so ist es in
artikel 11 des un sozialpakt es
verbrieft wir unterstützen das mit dem
neu geschaffenen
bundesbauministerium gegeben dem baum
den wohn und der stadtentwicklung wieder
den stellenwert den sie verdienen
mit einem gestärkten ressort fokussieren
wir uns darauf bezahlbaren wohnraum für
alle zu schaffen
bundesministerin gallwitz hat ihre klare
vorstellungen zum sozialen wohnungsbau
gerade im vorgetragen mit der klima
milliarde denken die klimaschutz und
bezahlbaren wohnraum zusammen das ist
der maßgebliche ansatz der spd
bundestagsfraktion
dafür danke geben
gemeinsam mit unseren koalitionspartner
stehen wir für eine koalition des
fortschritts und es recht im bereich
bauen und wohnen darum begrüße ich die
bauoffensive von 400.000 neuen wohnungen
pro jahr ein viertel davon öffentlich
gefördert und damit mietpreis gebunden
es muss noch in unserem land möglich
sein dass junge familien mit normalen
einkommen wohneigentum er werden können
eigentümer ist im übrigen immer noch die
beste absicherung und das auch im alter
der kollege herbst hat sich auch schon
gesagt dass kommerzielle großprojekt
ihrer mit ihren geschäftsmodellen
zugunsten einiger weniger massiv
subventioniert werden damit müssen wir
jetzt mal aufhören
wir haben uns im koalitionsvertrag
darauf verständigt mehr menschen in
deutschland zu ermöglichen den
selbstgenutzten wohneigentum zu wohnen
wir werden dafür die hürden senken
beispielsweise durch die unterstützung
eigenkapital ersetzen den darlehen
tilgungszuschüsse und zinsverbilligung
beim eigentumserwerb
dazu wollen wir kfw programme wie den
kauf von genossenschaftsanteilen stärken
und die mittel der höhe einmal nachlesen
oben qual für unsere mieter vor uns
nicht einen etat mit mehr als 4,9
milliarden euro gesamtausgaben
sicherheit im wandel bedeutet
bezahlbarer wohnraum für jung und alt
wir legen jetzt den grundstein für das
innovative bauen der zukunft
für den sozialen wohnungsbau stehen im
regierungsentwurf 750 millionen euro
bereit das erhöhte wohngeld starten wir
mit 895 millionen euro aus auch die
gestiegenen energiepreise haben ja schon
zügig reagiert und entlastung auf den
weg gebracht der einmaligen
heizkostenzuschuss hilft rund 2,1
millionen bürgerinnen und bürgern davon
rund 1,6 millionen wohngeldempfängern
und empfängerin
die wohnungsbauprämie soll auf 180
millionen euro das baukindergeld sogar
auf 995 millionen euro erhöht werden ich
halte das für den richtigen ansatz im
bereich stadtentwicklung wollen wir mit
mehr als 1,1 milliarden förder und die
städte und gemeinden sollen mit den
städtebau förderung bei der nachhaltigen
bewältigung des sozialen
wirtschaftlichen und ökologischen
wandels vom bund unterstützt werden
155 millionen euro stellen wir für
programme im quartiersmanagement zur
verfügung und machen damit die quartiere
zu lebendigen nachbarschaft die
grundlagen sollen im vorliegenden
haushaltsentwurf gelegt die entlastung
der städte und gemeinden haben wir im
blick wir werden den haushaltsberatungen
mit ihnen in den entscheidungen gering
bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
in china gute beratung
[Applaus]
die nächste rednerin musik-cds uns wir
nun wie dem lebensechten drei es im
ausschuss für stadtentwicklung gewesen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der frau
ministerin garwitz es ist schon gut und
schön dass es nun diesen einzelplan 25
in dieser legislaturperiode gibt aber
eins haben sie vergessen liebe frau
ministerin hier zu erwähnen die ein oder
andere im haus wird sich noch daran
erinnern die letzte das letzte
selbstständige
bundesbauministerium wurde 1998 von der
rot-grünen koalition unter gerhard
schröder aufgelöst viele behaupteten
damals deutschland sei fertig gebaut und
man sieht daran dass ist gerd schröder
er hat schröder nicht nur bei dieser
frage wie bei vielen anderen fragen bis
heute falsch liegt
der bedarf an zusätzlichem wohnraum in
deutschland ist heute riesig ja gerade
aber nicht nur in den ballungsgebieten
die ampelkoalition die ampel parteien
haben das in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
auch festgestellt und sich wirklich
große ziele gesetzt sie haben gesagt wir
wollen 400.000 wohnungen bauen in
deutschland und natürlich davon 100.000
sozialwohnungen sehr ambitioniert es
hier kann ich nur sagen aber leider
lässt weder der koalitionsvertrag noch
ihr geschäftsverteilungsplan noch hier
dieser erste haushaltsentwurf erkennen
wie sie dieses ziel nun wirklich
erreichen wollen im koalitionsvertrag
findet sich leider außer wolkigen worten
nichts konkretes das neue ministerium
das ministerium mit dem schönen titel
wohnen stadtentwicklung und bauwesen und
schon der name zeigt das bauen gar nicht
so wichtig genommen wird von der ampel
ist wieder her langem ein kollege sagte
ulrich lange ein königreich ohne land
wichtige kompetenzen sind bei den
anderen ministerien
angesiedelt also beim wirtschafts und
klimaministerium im justizministerium
oder auch im finanzministerium
leider müssen wir feststellen
den ehrgeizigen ziel von 400.000 neuen
wohnungen kommen wie mit ihren werken
koalitionsvertrag und auch mit dieser
geschäftsordnungs verteilung nicht viel
näher die bundes wohnen ministerin das
klingt zwar komisch aber wir werden uns
daran gewöhnen weil sie den namen ja so
gewählt haben also die bundes wohnen
ministerin kann man fast schon ein
bisschen leidtun recht häufig wird sie
in zukunft darauf verweisen müssen und
sagen ich habe nichts damit zu tun tut
mir leid ist nicht mein ressort wenden
sie sich bitte an die anderen
ministerien
ich bin da nicht schuld und ich frage
mich dann ob die anderen häuser auch die
verantwortung mit ihnen teilen wenn sie
frau ministerin gallwitz wie
beabsichtigt die zahlen an neubauten
eben nicht erreichen werden was wird
herr habeck sagen dass ritalin sagen
oder was wird der buschmann als
justizminister dazu sagen wird er die
verantwortung übernehmen für die nicht
erreichten ziele ich bin gespannt das
neue ministerium wird aber nicht nur im
koalitionsvertrag und auch bei den
kompetenzen kurs gehalten sondern wir
sehen heute es wird doch kurz gehalten
bei den haushaltsmitteln zwei spiele
will ich ihnen nennen
fangen wir beim sozialen wohnungsbau
100.000 neue wohnungen haben sie gesagt
wollen sie pro jahr bauen und natürlich
sollen wie möglichst auch
klimafreundlich sein sehr gut wunderbar
das wären vier mal so viele wohnungen
wie in den letzten jahren jedes jahr
gebaut wurden wir sehen auf eine
erhöhung der mittel sehr gut
aber wie sie sich drehen und wenden
wollen auf eine vervierfachung der
mittel kommen sie nicht
und selbst wenn sie auf die
vervierfachen kämen das hat mein kollege
eben auch schon angesprochen wir haben
steigende baukosten und wir haben
natürlich auch weitere verschärfungen
beim klimaschutz die sie planen und die
werden dazu führen dass natürlich die
mittel auch so nicht ausreichend sie
brauchen mehr als eine vervierfachung
aber davon finde ich nichts in ihrem
haushaltsplan
sind natürlich noch einen ausweg den
finden wir auch nicht aber sie
kommunizieren ja auch nicht mit den
länder ja ausweg könnte sein sie geben
die aufgabe dahin wo sie hingehört
nämlich an den länder- und sein ist es
eure aufgabe gestellt ihr die mittel zur
verfügung aber das haben sie bislang
nicht gesagt ich bin gespannt ob sich in
zukunft sagen wenn dann wäre ihr
koalitionsvertrag auch in diesem punkt
ein vertrag zulasten dritter
thema 2 städtebauförderung seit einigen
jahren sieht der bundeshaushalt bei
steigenden preisen dafür die gleiche
summe vor voreilig sie haben es erwähnt
4 790 millionen euro das ist kein
ruhmesblatt mit dem siegel schmücken
können
2021 hatte nämlich olaf scholz damals
bundesfinanzminister eine erhöhung
dieser mittel verhindert und das obwohl
wir gesagt haben wir brauchen zb
ansprach flächen
sanierungsprogramm und das wollten wir
auch aber es gab keine weiteren mittel
dazu für 2022 möchte jetzt ebenso und
als bundeskanzler aber ebenso olaf
scholz offenbar auch nicht seiner
vertrauten bundes wohnen ministerin eine
erhöhung der mittel für diesen wichtigen
aufgabenbereich zugestehen will ich
könnte diese aufzählung wirklich bis ins
unendliche fortsetzen und das bild würde
sich wirklich nicht ändern das neue
ministerium ist leider das muss ich
sagen der etikettenschwindel und mit
diesem haushalt werden sie ihre ziele
die sie verkündet haben auch niemals
erreichen wenn sie nicht erheblich
nacharbeiten ist es
offensichtlich dass sie ihre ziele
aufgäbe noch bevor sie die arbeit
angefangen haben sie bauen im moment
luft schlüsse und ich glaube ehrlich die
menschen in deutschland haben von ihnen
etwas anderes erwartet und sie haben
auch etwas anderes
vorgestellt ich hoffe sind die von noch
aber mit dem haushalt thusis nicht
dankeschön
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun kam hinterher zahlen
und hertha bsc ist obmann im ausschuss
für seine fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die
ministerin sehr geehrte damen und herren
frau h ich kann hier leider kein punkt
erwähnen wo ich sie inhaltlich
eingreifen kann weil sie an dem inhalt
überhaupt nicht angesprochen haben
wir alle
wir alle holen wollen ein schönes
bezahlbares und lebenswertes zu hause
gerade auch im home office und in der
quarantäne bis zum 24
februar dieses jahres ging es darum wie
wir schaffen bezahlbares wohnen mit den
klimazielen in einklang zu bringen jetzt
in der aktuellen zeitenwende geht es
auch darum dass wir sowohl um leben dass
wir unabhängig werden von putins
fossilen energien
die krisen bringen leider bis in unser
wohnzimmer vor wenn wir überhaupt eins
haben wir befinden uns in einer
zeitenwende
darauf muss jetzt auch eine bau wende
folgen und frau h das sagte ihn hier
noch mal ganz unklar die bau wende wird
kommen meine damen und herren
denn genau
genau diese bau wende will finanziert
werden dafür stehen wir bündnisgrüne
dafür steht die koalition die mieten
steigen bis ins unermessliche und gleich
seite singt der sozial wohnungsbestand
in den keller vor allem auch in
ostdeutschland
leidtragende dieses immer größer werden
denn es abgrund sind menschen mit
wohnberechtigungsschein
hier investieren wir zwei milliarden für
dieses jahr und insgesamt 14,5
milliarden bis 2026
das ist nämlich ein erster vorgeschmack
auf das was wir uns in der akl koalition
vorgenommen haben denn
jeder euro den wir jetzt investieren
muss ein sozial ökologischer euro sein
[Applaus]
dabei
dabei müssen wir auch so uns auch immer
bewusst sein dass wir momentan in einer
material krise sind putins angriffskrieg
sorgt für lieferengpässe
von baumaterialien und abermals wie
enorme preissteigerungen
wie es bereits in der energiewirtschaft
geplant ist müssen wir auch in der
bauwirtschaft unabhängiger von rohstoff
und materiallieferungen werden die
lösungen sind recycling sind
mining also das bauen aus dem bestand
und der umstieg auf regional verfügbare
baustoffe wie holz stroh oder leben das
konkret sind die zutaten für eine sozial
ökologische bau wende dafür
dafür haben wir im koalitionsvertrag
auch eine nationale holzbau strategie
als wichtigen baustein für eine
klimagerechte neubau offensive verankert
dieser strategie soll im haushalt
substanziell untersetzt werden
an anderer stelle sind wir besser
ausgestattet denn je bis 2025
investieren wir drei mal so viel in
energieeffiziente gebäude die bisher
eingeplant denn hier können wir die
meisten heizkosten sparen das klima
bestmöglich schützen und zukunftsgerecht
bauen
dass das alles bisher nicht umgesetzt
werden konnte liegt allein an einer
fraktion in diesem haus und das ist die
cdu csu fraktion
jetzt aber
jetzt ist unsere chance um so schnell
wie möglich die gebäude in den blick zu
nehmen die an schlechtesten gedämmt sind
denn diese haben im letzten jahr wieder
am meisten dazu beigetragen dass der
gebäudesektor seine klimaziele abermals
haushoch verfehlt hat das darf uns nicht
noch einmal passieren und genau deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt dringend eine
sozial-ökologische bau wenn dann aber
[Applaus]
setzten sich eigentlich wohnen allein
aber das geschieht nicht von allein und
deshalb muss die bau wende angemessen
auch in diesem haushalt eingepreist
werden
wie kann wohnraum geschaffen werden
darüber diskutiert der bundestag und
gerade jetzt mit der ukraine krise
werden natürlich auch immer
teurer holz wurde hier schon
angesprochene strömen auch bei den
energiepreisen gab es ja eine deutliche
teuerung
roger beck kam jetzt für die afg
fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
frau ministerin
diese regierung behauptet die see ist
als zeichen des respekts dass die die
hart arbeiten gut davon leben und auch
gut davon wohnen können so sagt dennis
frau ministerin gab es kürzlich im hause
frau ministerin wenn sie so etwas sagen
dann schwindeln sie sie tun nämlich
alles damit genau das nicht so ist sie
sagen zum beispiel jedes jahr sollten
400.000 neue wohnungen gebaut werden
100000 davon im sozialen wohnungsbau
dadurch werde wohl wieder für mehr leute
bezahlbar aber das stimmt jetzt schon
nicht und wird auch in zukunft nicht
stimmen und sie wissen das wieder werden
sie viele wohnungen gebaut noch besser
sich etwas für die vier wohnungssuche
und sie sagen wurden soll keine luxus
für wenige sondern lebensgrundlage für
alle sein aber sie verschweigen dabei
den zielkonflikt zwischen bezahlbare
wohnen und milliardenschweren
klimaschutzmaßnahmen auch das also ein
wunschtraum jedenfalls wenn es bezahlbar
sein aber schauen wir uns an was diese
regierung im bereich wohnungspolitik
konkret vorhat
schwerpunkt der politik oder auch der
finanziellen mittel ist hier vor allem
das wohngeld mit 895 millionen euro
wohngeld wird anteilig je zur hälfte von
bund und den ländern geleitet damit
einkommensschwächere haushalte
oberhalb der grundsicherung die
wohnkosten für angemessenen
wohnraum tragen können ein weiterer
schwerpunkt sind die gut zwei milliarden
euro für den sozialen wohnungsbau als
unterstützung für die bundesländer mit
diesen mitteln soll die
wohnraumversorgung der haushalte
unterstützt werden die sich am markt
auch eben nicht angemessen versorgen
können und auf unterstützung angewiesen
sind diese regierung und diejenigen der
länder setzen also viele milliarden für
einen zuschuss zur miete und
vergünstigte wohnung ein die idee
dahinter ist diesmal das gleiche
bezahlung wurde um die million menschen
unserem land die über den
einkommensgrenzen für wohngeld und
sozialwohnung liegen haben davon
natürlich nichts und das sind die
allermeisten aber und diese frage stellt
hier niemand niemand zu keiner zeit was
sind denn die ursachen dafür dass gerade
in den städten wohnraum für die meisten
geldbeutel knapp ist und bleibt warum
viel zu viel wohnraum für mieter vor
allem günstiger wohnraum denn darauf
kommt es für die meisten menschen an nun
in einer antwort der regierung auf eine
ausdrückliche afg anfrage zu umfang und
ursachen der wohnungsknappheit heißt es
hierzu ganz allgemein zitat zudem haben
bevölkerungszuwächse in metropolen
großstädten und universitätsstädten zu
wohnraum verknappung der letzten jahre
beigetragen
sie sind eine folge der urbanisierung
organisieren also es gibt zu wenig
wohnraum aber die vielen städten bei
dauert zu viele leute nach wohnraum
nachfragen interessante erkenntnis
simone es finden sich hinein sie wussten
das schon interessant dann frage ich sie
gefragt denn danach wer ist das denn wie
viele leute sind das denn und wieso
fragen sie dort nach antworten dieser
bundesregierung fehlanzeige
diese regierung tut was sie kann um zu
verbergen dass sie nicht kann was sie
tut anders ausgedrückt diese regierung
schafft ist bei der nachfrage nach den
ursachen der wohnungsknappheit und
steigen mit preis an vielen orten des
landes nicht einmal den begriff
einwanderung zu benutzen diese regierung
den offensichtlich in einer lila laune
regenbogen wird und sich alles selbst
bekommt und wenn sie jetzt wieder in mir
und genau das erleben wir gerade er ich
denke ich doch zu nennen dass hass und
hetze von ihrer seite diesmal ihre
üblichen reflexe ausleben rassismus usw
blablabla dann bleibt sie doch die
antwort schuldig warum gibt es in
unserem land für immer weniger menschen
bezahlbaren wohnraum und was hat die
einwanderung damit zu tun erklären sie
das den leuten noch mal denn sie sie
alle haben diese einwanderung eine der
wesentlichen ursachen für den wählenden
von wohnraum zugelassen und gefördert
und sie sind damit selbst verursacher
dieser sozialen frage
jemand machten wir einen strich durch
ihre koloss politik und das sind sie
selbst aber das sehen sie nicht und sie
wollen es auch nicht sehen ganz nach dem
motto migration findet bei mir vor der
haustür statt also ist ja auch kein
problem aber
woanders leben die menschen nicht in so
einer bornierten idylle wird diese
regierung vor anders finde diese
migration statt und wird mit hohen raum
versorgt beispiel
750 wohnungen wurden etwa im hamburger
bezirk bergedorf am mittleren land weg
führt zunächst 2500 sogenannte
flüchtlinge auf steuerzahlerkosten aus
dem boden gestampft ein neubau der in
ingolstadt im rahmen eines wohnprojektes
für angeblich minderjährige flüchtlinge
errichtet wurde ist nach zwei jahren ein
fall für eine vollumfängliche sanierung
den erstbezug übergeben und voll
möblierten wohnungen müssen laut eines
berichts des donaukuriers komplett
saniert werden in norderstedt ich glaube
spd regiert hatte das dortige
sozialdezernat eine für 25 millionen
euro geplante igel nagelneue 2002
quadratmeter große wohnanlage erst
einmal nur für neubürger vorgesehen in
dem wohnkomplex sollten unter anderem 18
10 unterkünfte entstehen um bisherigen
zitat konflikt erfahrungen aus dem wege
zu gehen wie schön für alle beteiligten
an der sandstraße leverkusen war
persönlich da interessiert die stadt
über 18 millionen euro in moderne
neubauten
450 sogenannte flüchtlinge und so weiter
und so weiter das ließe sich beliebig
fortsetzen für jede deutsche stadt dazu
passt auch ich komme zum haushalt zurück
ganz konkret dazu passt auch das
förderprogramm zur kriminalprävention
durch einfach sicherung für
privathaushalte die schon länger hier
leben in höhe von 35 millionen euro
jedenfalls im haushalt des ministeriums
dieses förderprogramm gibt es übrigens
seit november 2015 zeitliche
zusammenhänge mit anderen ereignissen
damals sind rein zufällig
es bleibt festzuhalten
viele wohnungen viele wohnungen fehlen
sie fielen für einheimische egal ob
deutsche türken polen italiener sonst
werden und diese leute die selbst viele
mieter aufkommen nämlich durch ihrer
hände arbeit
ziehen sich immer weniger der lade
bezahlbare wohnungen zu erhalten sie
sind die dummen die die wohnung und
anderer finanzieren uns selbst nicht
darin wohnen können sie erinnern sich an
ihre schwindelei frau ministerin sie
alle hier und damit meine ich wirklich
alle sie ganz besonders natürlich sie
haben das zugelassen zurückgeführt
zuerst kamen die fachkräfte dann die
ortskräfte und zuletzt die afrikanischen
schriften aus der ukraine und das
einzige was sie je davon mitkriegen ist
dass die lichterkette von der wohn und
ein bisschen heller leuchtet wie schön
für sie aber ihr handels zutiefst
unmoralisch ist nennt sich in länder
feindlichkeit und mit blick auf die
aktuelle lage wird noch einmal
deutlicher dass der millionenfach die
falsche ins land gelassen haben es sind
bereits mindestens 300.000 wirkliche
flüchtlinge aus der ukraine bei uns die
wir gerne aufnehmen auch noch mehr für
schutz auf zeit frauen kinder aus der
ukraine ja du hast frauen kinder und
nicht wehrfähigen männer aus pakistan
nigeria und tunesien ein guter alter
brauch bei vielen völkern frau und
kinder zuerst ich darf euch darauf
hinweisen die politik die wir wollen
nennt man in länder freundlich vielen
dank
[Applaus]
4,9 milliarden euro so hoch ist der etat
für das bundesministerium für die er
nicht wagen jetzt weiß wann sich
ebenfalls nach wunsch der
koalitionsfraktion die fdp ist teil
dieser koalition für die fraktion
spricht jetzt hagen reinhold
für den band kampfhunde sind und hetze
da fehlt mir jetzt die redezeit für das
ignoriere ich die langen leitlinie und
die herausforderungen im haushalt hat
ministerin
die ministerin und die vorher schon
dargestellt erlauben sie mir jetzt als
maurermeister nach meinem ingenieurs
kollegen dass ein praxis check zu
unterziehen und tatsächlich gibt es mehr
als genug probleme aktuell
lieferengpässe ja nicht nur aus der
kolonialzeit und die abgerissenen
lieferketten die wir schon haben
preissteigerungen baumaterial schon seit
vielen monaten jetzt kommt dieser
schreckliche ukraine konflikt mit dazu
und der verdeutlicht uns immer mehr die
abhängigkeit von ausländischen
rohstoffen und deshalb ist es richtig
und die lösung dafür finden sich nicht
erst seit drei wochen gott sei dank im
koalitionsvertrag einer fortschritts
koalition die nämlich schon erkannt hat
dass es richtig ist regionale produkte
zu verwenden regionale baumaterialien
ihre zeit haltbar leicht demontierbar
gebäude passt der aufzeigt welche
materialien drin sind das sind die hütte
und dem koalitionsvertrag schon weit
davor standen und jetzt wichtiger denn
hier sind ich will dir das an einem
beispiel
an einem beispiel kurz zeigen oder holz
rede ich gar nicht was der mangel an
holz betrifft das habe ich die letzten
monate schon davor diskutieren können
wir brauchen 4,1 millionen tonnen
bitumen in deutschland mehr als 30
prozent daraus aus russischem öl und das
meiste von russischen firmen das
brauchen wir für straßenbauprojekte
genauso für die abdichtung jedes
einzelnen hauses und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir davon loskommen deshalb
braucht es notfallplan für baumaterial
und das in zweierlei hinsicht 1 was im
haushalt hinterlegt ist und nicht nur im
haushalt der ministerin sondern darüber
haus natürlich auch in kiew da sind 30
millionen für den grünen leitmarkt stahl
100 millionen für anpassung urbane räume
an den klimawandel 30 millionen für
konstruktionstechnik und werkstoffe für
emissionsfreie industrie 40 millionen
für ressourceneffizienz forschung und
entwicklung im baubereich wir haben
internationale rohstoff patenschaft mit
95,5 millionen hinterlegt zehn millionen
mehr als vorher 120 millionen 4 und 2
vermeidet in der grundstoffindustrie
richtig und wichtig richtig im haushalt
adressiert dauerte eine weile bis das
umgesetzt wird und deshalb will ich
unser augenmerk auf folgendes heben wir
haben dass die bbc
dies ist die zulassungsbehörde für neue
baumaterialien vielen baumaterialen
gelingt erst jetzt mit der
preissteigerung der markteintritt und
das ist ein institut der länder und des
bundes die müssen jetzt in einem
schnellen plan der ohe was ist ein
baumaterial was lieferengpässe helfen
kann zu vermeiden indem wir neue
materialien dafür einführen und wo haben
wir gerade da wo wir vor ziele noch in
materialien zu stecken haben thema
dämmung und viele andere mehr
ersatzstoffe die nur darauf warten
zugelassen zu werden viele warten viele
jahre darauf das können wir uns
heutzutage gar nicht leisten wir
brauchen jetzt die super neue
baumaterialien
selbstverständlich auch in der zulassung
übrigens das auch schon adressiert im
koalitionsvertrag der fortschritt
koalition den wir aufgeschrieben haben
wenn wir das machen verhindern will dass
in den nächsten monaten der praxis check
uns einem harten urteil unterzieht und
wir feststellen auf den baustellen wären
wir unsere ziele gar nicht erfüllen
können weil uns die wichtigen
baumaterialien dort fehlen deshalb
braucht es jetzt schnelle
zulassungsverfahren von neuen
materialien nachhaltig ressourcen schont
regional das bedeutet auch viele von uns
müssen sich umgucken wenn sie in den
landkreisen demnächst über gipsabbau zum
beispiel in deutschland diskutieren ich
weiß dass es hart aber es tut not sonst
werden wir an unseren zielen scheitern
und wie wichtig es ist nachhaltig zu
werden das haben alle spätestens seit
drei wochen erkannt das freut mich dass
viele auf diesem weg mitmachen und im
koalitionsvertrag unabhängig von ihrer
farbe eigentlich mit unterschreiben
musste nicht angehen
[Applaus]
caren lay ist als nächstes angekündigt
sie ist die sprechweise jährigen
bauunternehmer die politik der
linksfraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ungebrochener
mietenwahnsinn
anhaltende wohnungsnot zusätzlicher
bedarf an bezahlbaren wohnungen durch
ukrainische geflüchtete massiv steigende
strom- und heizkosten
notwendige investitionen in den
klimaschutz da braut sich eine explosive
mischung auf dem wohnungsmarkt zusammen
aber der vorliegende haushaltsentwurf
ist mich geeignet diesen
herausforderungen gerecht zu werden
hunderttausend.de sozialwohnungen soll
dem jahr einen stehen schön wäre es aber
zur wahrheit gehört dass er im
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf gerade
einmal 2 milliarden euro drin stehen das
sind übrigens genau die gleichen zwei
milliarden euro die die gruppe schon im
august letzten jahres vorgelegt hatte
das verkaufen sie uns heute zum zweiten
mal
dass uns heute als großen
verhandlungserfolg der ampel zu
präsentieren so geht es nicht
aber angenommen dass diese 14 milliarden
euro tatsächlich kommen wurden in fünf
jahren das wurde also 2,9 milliarden
euro pro jahr bedeuten das ist natürlich
viel zu wenig um davon 100.000
sozialwohnungen zu bauen also meine
damen und herren das wissen sie glaube
ich auch selbst und da ist noch nicht
mit eingerechnet dass er jedes jahr
deutlich mehr sozialwohnungen aus der
bindung fallen als neuem so gebaut
werden können das bedeutete am ende der
letzten legislatur ein minus von 140.000
sozialwohnungen unterm schnitt und sie
können wirklich froh sein wenn sie die
am ende dieser legislaturperiode bei
null rauskommen
dass es auch anders geht das beweist die
ampel selbst 100 ja ein sondervermögen
für aufrüstung also das geld plötzlich
da davon ließen sich 25 millionen
sozialwohnungen bauen meine damen und
herren sie setzten die falschen
prioritäten
wir jetzt linke fordern 10 milliarden
jährlich für den sozialen wohnungsbau
einmal sozialwohnungen immer
sozialwohnung das muss in zukunft gelten
und das erreichen wir nur mit einer
neuen wohnungs gemeinnützigkeit und die
lese ich zwar im koalitionsvertrag aber
leider nicht im haushaltsentwurf das
muss sich dringend ändern denn ansonsten
wird es nichts mit einer soziale
wohnungspolitik vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die spd-fraktion spricht nun die
kollegin verena hubert
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
bezahlbares wohnen ist eine der sozialen
fragen unserer zeit und deswegen ist es
ein wichtiges zeichen dass wir nach 1998
endlich wieder das bauministerium
geschaffen haben
liebe frau ministerin mit dem
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf packen sie
und wir die wichtige aufgabe die
wichtige aufgabe gemeinsam an 400.000
wohnungen pro jahr wollen wir bauen da
von 100.000 sozial geförderter wohnraum
und damit schaffen wir angebot auf den
so angespannten wohnungsmarkt und es
braucht dafür geld und investitionen
14,5 milliarden euro werden wir von 20
22 bis 26 bereitstellen für den sozialen
wohnungsbau und damit und das kann man
ja auch mal ganz deutlich sagen haben
wir die mittel im vergleich zur
vorgängerregierung verdreifacht fast
aber es geht natürlich
nicht nur um geld ist ja schön aber wir
müssen ja auch zum bauen kommen deswegen
ist eine der ganz wichtigen aufgaben im
koalitionsvertrag die planungs
beschleunigung wie bauen wir bürokratie
ab wie geht das ganze auch schneller wie
gehen wir über verwaltungsmodernisierung
aber auch digitalem wege schneller zu
den wohnungen aber allen bauprojekten in
diesem land und da haben wir auch ein
ganz wichtiges mittel das sogenannte bim
building information modeling also dass
man an plänen auch mit standards
vernetzt
gleichzeitig auch arbeiten kann und
somit eben nicht alles schwerfällig und
nacheinander sondern wir eben auch das
thema schnell auf die strecke bringen
und schnell
ist auch mein zweiter stichpunkt es geht
um schnelles bauen da haben wir uns auch
mal ein bisschen was wird schon gut
erprobt es geht um serielles modulares
bauen da kann man auch mal ein blick auf
die automobilindustrie werfen da können
dinge vorgefertigt werden die dann an
der baustelle auch schneller zusammen
gepackt werden und natürlich sehen wir
auch einiges an innovationen in der
baubranche
guckt man sich roboter an die mit zum
einsatz kommen aber auch materialien die
wir eben angesprochen haben welche
materialien verbauen während der zukunft
neben holz es gibt ganz viel forschung
hin nicht nur zu klimaneutralen sondern
auch zu kleben klima negativen
materialien und das sorgt auch ein stück
weit für entlastung und weniger
abhängigkeit von globalen lieferketten
und wenn wir über innovationen am bau
reden dann geht es natürlich auch nicht
ohne den 3d drucker hier mal zu erwähnen
da wird mit zement tatsächlich auch
schon das passende teil in dem richtigen
moment auch vor ort ganz konkret
geschaffen und deswegen und das ist mir
auch ganz wichtig ist dieses ministerium
auch ein transformations- und werden und
vor allem neue wege gehen
und es geht um klima und sozial
gerechtes bauen und das ist ein und das
eine sind die mietkosten das andere sind
die nebenkosten
wir haben hier in der vergangenen woche
gemeinsam den heizkostenzuschuss auf den
weg gebracht das hilft kurzfristig aber
wir brauchen mittel und langfristig
natürlich weitere entlastungen da geht
es darum wie wir eigentlich
bauen mit zu welcher gesamtenergiebilanz
wir kommen gerade wenn man sich die co2
bilanz des gebäudes sektors anschaut
sind wir bei rund ein drittel der co2
emissionen und deswegen haben wir auch
einen ganz wichtigen schwerpunkt in
diesem haus auf klimaneutrales bauen und
sanieren gelegt und wir werden da auch
gezielt auf vernetzte ansätze setzen
also quartiers ansätze vernetzte städte
und das ist eben auch eine lösung ein
baustein raus aus diesem aus der
abhängigkeit und hin zu den erneuerbaren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eine
herausforderung die wir so nicht
vorgesehen haben sind natürlich all die
menschen die gerade fliehen vor krieg in
der ukraine
viele ehrenamtliche in diesem land
gemeinsam mit den kommunen öffnen ihre
türen
und toren und es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir hier auch als politik als
bundespolitik weiter unterstützend dabei
sind damit wir mittel für den umbau für
den aufbau und für die schaffung von
gebäuden zur verfügung stellen
der entwurf des bundeshaushaltes bildet
und bietet eine gute grundlage
all das zu schaffen was wir uns
vorgenommen haben
es geht aber nicht nur mit geld sondern
es geht mit einer gemeinsamen
kraftanstrengung
deswegen liebe frau ministerin dass sie
ein bündnis für bezahlbaren wohnraum
einsetzen ist genau der richtige weg
alle akteure an einen tisch zu bringen
und wir packen das gemeinsam an und
darauf freue ich mich mit allen
gemeinsam auch sehr
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion hat nun dr jan
marco luczak passwort jan marco luczak
ist sprecher für wohnen stadtentwicklung
bauwesen und kommunen seiner fraktion
frau präsidentin männer wie sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wir
befinden uns in der haushaltswoche und
wir sprechen hier und heute über den
einzelplatz 25 dort wo es um das bauen
und das wohnen geht und das ist ein
existenzielles thema und mir ist ganz
wichtig es geht hier nicht alleine um
die drögen zahlen es geht nicht darum
mathematisch zu analysieren welche titel
gibt es dort im haushaltsplan welche
ansätze sind es sondern ein
haushaltsplan das ist auch immer in
zahlen die runde politik und da wo es
jetzt schon spannend hier kommt es
nämlich darauf an und hier kann man
ablesen wie ernst ist die ampel mit all
den schönen dingen meinen die im
koalitionsvertrag formuliert sind und da
kann man auch ablesen wie die
durchsetzungskraft einer ministerin und
ihrer beiden parlamentarischen
staatssekretäre sind und da muss man
schon sagen da klaffen anspruch und
wirklichkeit dann doch erheblich
auseinander meine damen und herren denn
wenn wir uns mal anschauen was ist denn
eigentlich als erstes passiert als
erstes haben sie erstmal einen abrupten
grafiker stopp gemacht damit ist all das
was sie sich vorgenommen haben beim
neubau bei der bezahlbarkeit ist uns
beim klimaschutz all das ihre eigenen
ziele haben sie damit torpediert und vor
allen dingen vielen tausenden menschen
jungen familien die sich die eigenen
vier wände schaffen wollen den haben sie
von heute auf morgen den boden unter den
füßen weggezogen das war ihre erste
zentrale maßnahme das war ein großer
großer strategischer fehler
und das ganze
sie hat wirklich massiv vertrauen
zerstört und dann gab es öffentlichen
druck natürlich gab es zur öffentlichen
erheblichen öffnet und sie haben auch
eine kehrtwende oder so eine halbe
kehrtwende vollzogen haben dann gesagt
na gut wir setzen die förderung doch
irgendwie vor das ist jetzt zwei monate
her aber was ist seitdem denn eigentlich
passiert also eher 40 eine milliarde
soll es ja geben bis zum jahresende
befristet kann man bis heute nicht
beantragen sie haben gesagt es gibt ein
anschlussprogramm ja was denn von
anschlusspunkt haben es gibt bislang
keine
positionen dazu es gibt keine eckpunkte
nichts gibt es dazu und sie wissen ganz
genau dass man lange vorlaufzeiten bauch
wenn man hier plant und deswegen ist das
was sie dort gemacht haben das vertrauen
zerstört zu haben so ein elementarer
fehler gewesen und das wirklich jetzt
nachhängen und das würde ich ihn auch
ihre bilanz verhageln das kann ich jetzt
schon sagen
und jetzt gerade noch einen punkt hinzu
den will ich dann schon noch mal
herausarbeiten sie haben beim er 55
programm als zentrales argument
verwendet
das wird doch heute sowieso gebaut das
doch marktstandard so jetzt schaue ich
mir mal an was die ministerin mit den
ländern jetzt gerade vereinbart hat in
der verwaltungsvereinbarung wo es darum
geht beim sozialen wohnungsbau den klima
gerecht zu gestalten das ist eine
milliarde euro vergeben und sie haben
jetzt mit den ländern vereinbart dass es
beim neubau
geld gibt förderung vom bund wenn der
erhard 55 standard eingehalten wird
das verstehe ich jetzt irgendwie nicht
wenn sie auf der einen seite
argumentieren das ist doch alles mag
dann hat das baut man sowieso auf der
anderen seite aber sagen an der stelle
bei den ländern da geben wir jetzt geld
dazu das passt doch nicht zusammen dass
es widersprüchlich sie haben die an
dieser stelle riesige strategische
fehler gemacht und die kaschieren sie
jetzt an dieser stelle das passt nicht
zusammen und das werden wir aufdecken
hier auch in diesem hause
[Applaus]
und ich habe gerade schon gesagt auch
wenn es um die bezahlbarkeit des wurden
es gibt da waren die förderung bei der
kfw ganz zentral und sie haben ja gesagt
wo in 4.000 neue wohnungen bauen wir
werden wahrscheinlich am ende viel mehr
wo möglicherweise noch brauchen mit
blick auf die zahlen der flüchtlinge die
jetzt zu uns kommen und deswegen ist es
umso wichtiger dass wir nicht nur die
zahlen alleine schaffen sondern dass wir
natürlich auch schauen wo entstehen denn
diese wohnung ist eine allokation
probleme und wir müssen vor allen dingen
auch schauen welche wohnungen entstehen
ist müssen am ende bezahlbare wohnungen
seien und wenn wir dann aber wieder
einmal den realitätscheck macht was
steht denn da eigentlich im
koalitionsvertrag das finden sie vor
allen dingen kostentreiber sie finden
vor allen dingen das standen als
hochgesetzt werden dass sie an vielen
stellen weitere bauvorschriften auf den
weg bringen wollen die das bauen am ende
teuer machen und damit am ende auch das
mieten teurer machen damit machen sie
genau das gegenteil von dem was
eigentlich jetzt notwendig wäre wir
bräuchten eigentlich ein radikales
entspannungsprogramm um diese gewaltigen
herausforderung beim neubau und beim
bezahlbaren aber irgendwie stemmen zu
können um ihren koalitionsvertrag und im
haushalt findet sich nichts dazu das ist
eine falsche weichenstellung
und das will ich noch einen punkt
erwähnen der uns als union besonders
wichtig ist und der so hat es zumindest
in der vergangenheit immer verstanden
auch der fdp wichtig ist nämlich dass
beim thema eigentumsförderung und da
finden sich am koalitionsvertrag eine
ganze reihe von punkten da geht es um
eigenkapital ersetzt eine daneben
freibeträge bei der grunderwerbsteuer
tilgungszuschüsse zinsverbilligungen das
sind alles wohlklingende worte im
koalitionsvertrag und wir finden das
richtig als union weil es bei der
schaffung von eigentum was vier von fünf
menschen in deutschland wollen die
wollen den eigenen vier wänden wurde das
ist richtig weil es
gesamtgesellschaftlich positive effekte
hat war dass schutz vor steigenden
mieten gibt und was auch gut ist für die
altersvorsorge
so und jetzt frage ich sie mal herr
druck sie haben das im koalitionsvertrag
geschrieben und in dem haushaltsentwurf
findet sich von aldi punkten nichts kein
einziger haushaltsansatz was bei
eigenkapital als jetzt denn da der
freibeträge nichts findet sich dazu das
einzige was ich finde ich eine milliarde
euro für das baukindergeld und da haben
wir jetzt gerade von den kolleginnen von
kollegen von ihnen aus der ampel gehört
das finden sie aber alles furchtbar das
wollen sie am ende einfach nicht das ist
das was wir als große koalition noch auf
den weg gemacht haben wo wir über
300.000 familien auf den weg in die
eigenen vier wände geholfen haben das
ist das einzige was sie beim eigentum
jetzt fortführen weise fortführen müssen
nicht mal sich fortführen wollen das
haben ihre redner jetzt gerade gebracht
und muss ich sagen damit erweisen sie
die menschen in unserem land die in die
eigenen vier wänden leben einen tort
meine damen und herren das ist keine
vernünftige haushaltspolitik die wieder
an der stelle machen und das muss man
schon sagen auch die fdp sie haben ja
gerade hier habe es wieder gesagt dass
dieses eigentum eintreten sie sind
offensichtlich nur bei einer sehr
durchsetzungsstark wenn es um corona
geht da haben sie die ampel tatsächlich
am nasenring durch die manege geführt
aber wenn es darum geht eigentum zu
fördern wenn es darum geht junge
familien in den eigenen vier wänden zu
bringen da sind sie kriegen der ampel
ein totalausfall vielen herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun die kollegin anja liefert das
buch
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
putins brutaler angriffskrieg ist eine
zäsur und eine zeitenwende und millionen
menschen sind auf der flucht das leid
der menschen macht uns fassungslos
zerstörte städte sehen wir mitten in
europa
und vor diesem hintergrund sind
selbstverständlichkeiten wie die
sicherheit einer wohnung eine intakte
infrastruktur und lebenswerte städte das
bekommt jetzt eine ganz neue bedeutung
und das ist auch unsere aufgabe in
diesem politikbereich
wir spüren die auswirkungen auch hier
massiv steigende kosten für den
lebensunterhalt und die fossilen
energien und wir werden ein radikales
umdenken in der energiepolitik brauchen
wir werden prioritäten setzen und mittel
effektiv nutzen für den sozialen
zusammenhalt und ökologisch nachhaltige
projekte und
wir wollen neues wagen vielleicht schon
im nächsten haushalt in der er in
wenigen wochen schon beginnt erhoffen
wir uns mittel für die neue wohnungs
gemeinnützigkeit und vielleicht können
wir ja das geld was die fast eine
milliarde die aus dem baukindergeld so
langsam abschmelzen wird für so etwas
nutzer
und wir wollen nicht nur neues wagen wir
wollen auch altes überwinden und mit alt
meine ich die altschulden die viele
kommunen belasten finanzschwache
kommunen müssen besser unterstützt
werden sie brauchen die mittel gerade
der stadtentwicklung der
städtebauförderung dringend und
besonders um die lebensqualität zu
erhalten und die abwärtsspirale zu
durchbrechen
das heißt
wir müssen die lösung für die
altschulden finden und hier sind gerade
unionsländer auch mal in der pflicht ich
denke da an nordrhein westfalen und
ihren ministerpräsidenten herrn wüst der
sich als einer der wenigen
ministerpräsidenten standhaft weigert
eine lösung für die alt schon auf seiten
der länder herbeizuführen und da müssen
wir wirklich ran das kann so nicht
weitergehen
wir müssen aber auch die städte noch vor
dem müssen aber auch nach vorne schauen
und die städte nach der pandemie fit
machen der handel gastronomie hotels
kunst kultur alle sind bereit für den
neustart und dafür brauchen wir wirksame
mittel der städtebauförderung wie zb das
programm zukunftsfähige innenstädte und
zentren wir müssen aber auch schauen
dass die programme der
städtebauförderung
lernende programme sind und sie an die
aktuellen entwicklungen anpassen der
klimawandel ressourcenknappheit
demografischer wandel
all diese fragen brauchen neue antworten
und wir haben bereits gute programme und
vorhin wurde auch angesprochen das thema
sportstätten was können wir denn für die
kommunen tun leistungen soziale
integration im quartier und mit all
diesen programmen zusammen werden wir
jetzt 17 milliarden euro für die
städtebauförderung ausgeben und wir
grüne haben die klimaneutralität zu der
wir uns ja international verpflichtet
haben fest im blick
klimaanpassung muss ein fester baustein
in den programmen der städtebauförderung
seien und gestärkt werden
wir brauchen aber auch mehr
digitalisierung einen digitalisierung
schub mit den projekten zb smart cities
digitalisierung und klimaschutz müssen
wir zusammen denken und wir müssen die
menschen dabei mitnehmen mit lokaler
wertschöpfung
kreislaufwirtschaft verkehrswende
projekten bürgerbeteiligung für uns als
grüne steht die klimagerechtigkeit und
der soziale zusammenhalt im fokus das
schafft wirtschaftliche impulse und
nachhaltige lebensqualität für alle
menschen die hier leben und auch für die
die noch zu uns kommen und gemeinsam in
der fortschritts koalition werden wir
dafür die weichen stellen vielen dank
[Applaus]
anja siebert war das für bündnis 90/die
das modell mulligan hat ist der nächste
redner er ist mitglied der
unionsfraktion und auch mitglied des
haushaltsausschusses
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
lassen sie mich zum schluss dieser
debatte noch mal kurz zum
haushaltsvolumen zurückkommen wir reden
hier von etwa fünf milliarden euro drei
viertel davon investitionen 11 7
milliarden euro zuweisungen und
zuschüssen möchte kurz auf drei aspekte
eingehen zum teil wurde ist ja schon
genannt größter einzelposten in diesem
einzelplan 25 ist das baukindergeld mit
knapp einer milliarde euro
und meine damen und herren vor dem
hintergrund steigender mieten und
immobilienpreise ist die schaffung von
bezahlbarem wohnraum sicherlich eine der
größten herausforderungen unserer
heutigen zeit die stärkung der
wohneigentumsbildung insbesondere für
haushalte mit kindern ist neben dem
mietwohnungsmarkt ein zentrales
instrument dafür deshalb haben wir das
ja auch als cdu geführte koalition in
der vergangenen legislaturperiode
aufgelegt die eigene
die ärgern vier wände sind und bleiben
eine krisenfeste wertanlage und sind
eben auch ein wichtiger bestandteil auch
in der altersversorgung und das
baukindergeld dass wir eingeführt haben
das ist ein erfolg wurde der kürzlich
vorgelegte evaluationsbericht stellt
dazu fest ich zitiere der anteil der
familien mit kindern die ins
wohneigentum umzug hat sich durch das
baukindergeld im evaluierungs zeitraum
vervierfacht meine damen und herren das
baukindergeld
wird insbesondere von familien mit
niedrigen bis mittleren einkommen
genutzt ist wirkt darüber hinaus über
den eigentlichen eigentumserwerb hinaus
so gab es investitionen in höhe von etwa
22 milliarden euro im baugewerbe im
evolution evaluations zeitraum und von
der baukindergeld förderung geht auch
eine lenkungswirkung für den ländlichen
raum aus das trägt dann eben auch zur
stabilisierung schrumpfenden regionen
bei und entlastung die ballungsgebiete
aber und jetzt komme ich zum zentralen
punkt die auch für haushälter wichtig
ist aus der steigerung der
volkswirtschaftlichen produktion und den
beschäftigungseffekten die angestoßen
wurden durch das baukindergeld
resultieren einnahmen für die
öffentliche hand in höhe von 13
milliarden euro die generierten
staatseinnahmen übersteigen somit die
vom bund eingesetzten mittel 1 euro
fördermittel generiert etwa drei euro 70
staatseinnahmen meine damen und herren
das ist wahrlich ein erfolgs rütteln
und deshalb sage ich ihnen auch ganz
klar ich vermisse in ihrem haushalt wie
sie dann in zukunft das thema
wohneigentumsbildung angehen wollen und
ich sage ihnen ganz klar an dieser
stelle auch machen sie bitte nicht noch
einmal denselben fehler den sie schon
bei der eben schon angesprochenen kfw
förderung für energieeffiziente gebäude
gemacht haben stoppen sie keine
förderung irgendwie abrupt und über
nacht sorgen sie für plan sorgen sie
verlässlichkeit im interesse und zum
wohl der familien die darauf angewiesen
sind
ja meine damen und herren die
bundesregierung hat sich zum ziel
gesetzt pro jahr 400.000 neue wohnungen
zu bauen ein ambitioniertes ziel aber
ich sage ihnen mit geld allein ist das
auch nicht getan die bundesländer die
das ganze ja kofinanzieren und umsetzen
müssen haben sie schon an sie gewandt
frau ministerin die kapazitäten in der
bauverwaltung und in der bauindustrie
sind begrenzt durch neue standards die
sie einführen erhöhen sie die baukosten
und die bürokratie noch zusätzlich
abhilfe schaffen würde da zb ja auch
digitalisierung und deshalb das will ich
an der stelle ein marken bin ich froh
dass in meinem bundesland nämlich dem
saarland wo ich herkomme gerade am
vergangenen freitag der digitale
bauantrag freigeschaltet werden konnte
mit einer modernen landesbauordnung
gemeinsam und dem digitalen bauantrag
werden sich hier die genehmigungszeiten
deutlich verringern dass es gut das land
ist vorreiter in sachen digitaler
baurecht schaffung und deshalb wäre es
auch gut frau ministerin wenn das thema
digitalisierung eine größere rolle beim
bund spielen würde damit könnten sie
dann ganz konkret dafür sorgen dass
bauern in deutschland schneller und auch
billiger wird
nicht im haus ja meine damen und herren
im jahr 2020 ist die zahl der
wohnungseinbrüche glücklicherweise
bundesweit zurückgegangen das ist eine
gute entwicklung sicherlich auch
begünstigt durch viele home office durch
die korona pandemie dennoch haben
einbrecher einen schaden von 260
millionen euro verursacht und es gab
über 35.000 wohnungseinbruchs versuche
etwa die hälfte der einbrecher scheitert
vor 30 jahren waren es noch deutlich
weniger die scheitern und
ausschlaggebend sind dabei mittlerweile
die guten standards in technischen
ausrüstungen im besonders gesicherten
fenstern und türen und so waren bei
einer studie
suchten einbrüchen nur 1,05 aller
versuche erfolgreich sofern
zusatzsicherungen im einsatz waren und
der einbau ebendieser zusatzsicherung
wurde in den vergangenen jahren immer
gefördert durch das kfw programm
kriminalprävention für durch
einbruchsicherung und in diesem jahr
stellen sie nochmal etwas abgesenkt noch
35 millionen euro zur verfügung aber um
das programm dann auslaufen zu lassen
meine damen und herren das ist sehr
bedauerlich eigentumssicherung
einbruchschutz wird so geschwächt ich
würde sie führen sie auch dieses
wichtige programm zur sicherheit der
wohnungen in deutschland fort
summarum uns liegt ein haushaltsplan vor
der falsche prioritäten setzt weil
wichtigen und vielen förderprogrammen
verursachen sie unsicherheit und zum
teil haben sie auch aktuelle beschlüsse
nicht abgebildet wie der der erhöhte
heizkostenzuschuss dass es im haushalt
bisher nicht drin bei nahezu null
spielraum ich bin gespannt wie die
haushaltsberatungen verlaufen werden
vielen dank
markus uhl war das hier ganz deutliche
reaktionen von der zuständige ministerin
debatte die natürlich auch verfolgt
das bild bei der nächste rede
da spricht nämlich ein parteikollege
bernhard daldrup der sprecher für wohnen
stadtentwicklung bauwesen und kommunen
der spd fraktion
hätte frau ministerin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
die ampel hatte ja nach 100 tagen nicht
sozusagen zeit zur einarbeitung sondern
ist sofort gewissermaßen in einen
krisenmodus bestürzt worden der um die
unvorstellbare dimension des krieges
erweitert worden ist aber trotzdem bin
ich der auffassung dass der
koalitionsvertrag wie einige in der
veröffentlichen meinung vielleicht
darstellen wollen deshalb nicht so
makulatur geworden das ziel bis zu
400.000 wohnungen im jahr bauen zu
wollen darunter 100.000 sozialwohnungen
wird erst recht seit der aufnahme von
flüchtlingen nicht mehr in frage
gestellt sondern gestern man zum
beispiel kollege luczak und
ich und andere auch bei den privaten
wohnungsgesellschaften es wird
ausdrücklich unterstützt und gefordert
es ist also kein gemütlich und zu hoch
angelegte messlatte und ich will an
dieser stelle sagen umso wichtiger damit
das passieren kann war auch die bildung
eines eigenen ministeriums und ich weiß
aus vielen gesprächen das ministerium
geiwitz in den vergangenen 100 tagen
jedenfalls so viele gespräche mit der
wohnungswirtschaft geführt hat wie horst
seehofer in vier jahren nicht und das
ist glaube ich schon ein großer
unterschied und eine wichtige
unterscheidung auch und wenn sie gerne
an 20 jahre zurück erinnern mögen sie
das tun liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der cdu wir gucken lieber 20 jahre in
die zukunft also in die vergangenheit
wir haben den sozialen wohnungsbau in
der letzten wahlperiode durch änderung
des grundgesetzes wieder in die
mitverantwortung des bundes geruht liebe
merkel teil haben sie mit gestimmt das
war auch vernünftig und dafür fünf
milliarden bereitgestellt jetzt sind es
von 20 22 20 26 14,5 milliarden also
fast dreimal so viel wie im csu
geführten bundesinnenministerium und das
können sie ja kritisieren ich bin
gespannt auf die erhöhungs anträge die
von ihnen in dieser frage kommen ob sie
das tatsächlich mit dem sozialen
wohnungsbau so ernst meinen wie sie das
hier an dieser stelle sagen ich habe
zweifel daran ich bin jedenfalls sehr
dankbar für die ankündigung ministerin
dass sie dass das bündnis für das
soziale bauen in der kürze jedenfalls
beginnen sollten durch den grausamen
krieg werden immer mehr menschen zu uns
kommen die wir aus tiefer mit
menschlichkeit aufnehmen aus tiefer
mitmenschlichkeit und solidarität und
denen wir helfen wollen das werden sie
seitens der afg nie verstehen es ist gut
dass wir die damit verbundenen fragen
der aufnahme der unterbringung der
bildung der gesundheit und viele andere
fragen die damit verbunden sind dass sie
sie aufgreifen und behandelt ich danke
an dieser stelle sehr allen
ehrenamtlichen ich danke sehr den
kommunen an dieser stelle dass sie so
schnell und so hilfsbereit tätig gewesen
sind das ist glaube ich wissen wichtig
und ich erwarte auch dass bund und
länder gemeinsam am 17 april wenn das
programm fertig gestellt werden wird
hier auch die finanziellen konsequenzen
für die kommunen sichtbar werden lassen
für uns sozialdemokraten gilt auf jeden
fall und für die ampel glaube ich
insgesamt wir werden die kommunen nicht
im regen stehen lassen auf freitag werde
beispielsweise eine änderung des
baugesetzbuches dass wir intensiv
sowieso verändern wollen auf den weg
bringen das den bau von
flüchtlingsunterkünften schnell
ermöglicht die kfw hilft mit 250
millionen bei einem signals von -0 75
das ist auch ein wichtiger gesichtspunkt
und wenn wir aus der letzten großen
zuwanderung etwas gelernt haben dann
darf es keine soziale spaltung in diesem
land geben und deswegen ist dass die
begrenzung des mieten anstiegs der
wohnungsneubau die energetische
modernisierung all das bleibt weiterhin
wichtig und die explodierenden
nebenkosten tatsächlich die zweite miete
werden wir uns in den würden wir werden
wir vornehmen müssen und deswegen ist
auch der heizkostenzuschuss eine so
wichtige angelegenheit die haben wir in
dem koalitionsvertrag haben wir ihnen
rein geschrieben wir haben ihnen jetzt
ganz konkret umgesetzt und wir haben den
ursprungs betrag übrigens verdoppelt und
ich bedanke mich bei den linken dass sie
gesagt haben okay unser antrag war
geringer aber ihr habt einen besseren
den werden wir jetzt auch mit
unterstützen und ich bin schon ein
bisschen skurril wenn nun ausgerechnet
die union sagt bei einer verdopplung ja
das ist uns aber nicht genug dann macht
ihr euch wirklich ein bisschen naja
humoris humoristen das muss ich schon
sagen das finde ich jedenfalls ziemlich
skurrile situation wir werden sicher
weiter an der subjektförderung arbeiten
aber die objekts förderung bleibt
ausgesprochen wichtig und der voerder
abbruch bei kfw 55 ja das war ein
problem ich will das gar nicht
bestreiten und ich bedauere sehr dass
ist in eine solche situation gekommen
ist aber ihr seid pharisäer wie sie im
buche stehen denn ihr tragen maßgeblich
die verantwortung dafür um das jetzt
hier abziehen zu wollen das ist schon
recht problematisch und meine asten wert
auch nicht akzeptabel es gibt eine ganze
reihe punkte die wir hier erwähnen
müssen wir über den haushalt reden die
investitionsquote 361 milliarden die
städtebauförderung weiter auf dem
höchsten programm die zusätzlichen uni
lankas total vergessen 250 millionen für
die innenstädte ja wir haben sich denn
darum gekümmert jedoch nicht nach also
da sehe ich aber ganz anders
eigentumsförderung da redet über das
baukindergeld was ausläuft aber über die
genossenschafts förderung die habt
jedoch verhindert die wollte doch das
bmw nicht die kommt aber jetzt das ist
eine form von eigenen durch gelungen
auch in den städten wo menschen
das gar nicht mehr leisten wird es gibt
auch präsident komme zum schluss noch
eine ganze reihe punkte raumordnung die
ich gerne ansprechen würde die aus
zeitgründen jetzt nicht mehr möglich
sind ich glaube wir werden spannende
haushaltsberatungen bekommen und ich bin
sehr auf die weiter gehenden ausgabe
vorschläge und die einsparung der union
gespannt vielen dank
[Applaus]
nochmal auch auf die unstimmigkeiten in
der vorherigen koalition als es ja eine
große koalition aus union und spd
hingewiesen
nächster gegner ist der kollege daniel
kühs er ist der sprecher für bau und
wohnungspolitik der liberalen im
deutschen bundestag
soll er der frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich komm ich produkt vielen dank für den
hinweis ich muss den kolleginnen und
kollegen der union die man ja wirklich
in weiten teilen schätzen kann einfach
mal sagen wir können doch nicht erwarten
dass wir in 100 tagen das lösen was ihr
in vier jahren haben liegen lassen
deswegen mag ich doch mal ehrlich wir
haben hier in neuenstadt besonnene mit
einer bauministerin mit einem baum
ministerium der dringend notwendig war
weil wir ein land vorgefunden haben das
großes nachholbedarf hatte an
investitionen an geschwindigkeit an
innovationen dann zeigt er den finger
darüber und fordert hier sachen die die
spd ohne probleme zugestimmt hat also
macht euch bitte mal ehrlich in der
ganzen debatte
diese debatte zeigt er wirklich wirklich
viel was so nachhinein wie die letzten
vier jahre auch erklärt ich möchte noch
mal zum kollegen luxus sagen wer hier
hinter der hier fragt wie ernst meint es
die ampel der mit den vielen schönen
sachen koalitionsvertrag also erstens
danke für die anerkennung jahr stehen
viele schöne sachen koalitionsvertrag
und ich kann ihnen versprechen wir
meinen es völlig er wir werden die
weichen stellen im meer bauen schneller
bauen und günstiger bauen und dass wir
den bestand klimaneutral hinbekommen wir
werden das machen was wir fordern aber
an dem er gescheitert zeit und auch da
und auch da ich hier willst du dasselbe
jetzt vier jahre opposition gewesen und
ich verstehe dass es nicht so viel spaß
macht regieren und ich setze auch lieber
mit den neuen koalitionspartner in der
forschungs koalition tatsächlich die
weichen dass wir die probleme lösen die
gelegen die ringe blieben sind aber eine
sache muss dann muss ich sagen weil die
lange ja so viele fragen aufgeworfen hat
weil die lange so viele fragen
aufgeworfen hat wo sind denn nicht
fachkräfte ja da habt ihr recht die
frage ist berechtigt wir werden eine
eine fachkräfte initiative auf den weg
bringen wir werden die zuwanderung neu
regeln wir werden alle
exzellenzinitiative für die ausbildung
auf den weg bringen wir werden viel
machen um diese fragen die du zu recht
stellt zu beantworten aber man muss auch
feststellen nachdem mir das angehört
habe diese vielen fragen viele fragen
aber keine ideen und dann kommt ja ein
baukindergeld nur damit ich richtig
verstanden werde dies könne jede
jedem insbesondere familien dem der
staat geld geschenkt ich könnte es aber
man kann doch nicht haben das
baukindergeld hipp hurra war supergut
die eigentumsquote ist gesunken die
eigentumsquote ist gesucht nur zu
stellen euch nicht hier her und sagt
eigentum wäre wichtig da die von euch
installierte halteprämie ist nicht ist
gescheitert sie hat dazu geführt dass
sie einigen quote sinkt deswegen wir
sind offen für ideen wirklich geschätzt
eine konstruktive opposition aber da
muss neben den vielen fragen muss dann
aber auch tatsächlich mal was kommen
übrigens herr bekannten
ich tue ihnen den gefallen weil sie
gesagt haben keiner redet über
einwanderung in zusammenhang mit wohnung
deutschland ist ein einwanderungsland
wir brauchen die zuwanderung wir
brauchen fachkräfte die uns in unserem
land voranzubringen wollen sie sich hier
hinstellen und konnte von deutschland
freundlicher politik zu fabulieren dann
sage ich ihnen einst ihre politik ist
dumm am thema vorbei und hetzerisch und
die der ampel wir werden die war ich
noch fortschritte stellen und darauf
habe ich spaß und das wird auch machen
zu ihrer ersten rede im deutschen
bundestag hat nun die kollegin melanie
welling für die spd-fraktion
hatte frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen zum abschluss dieser
debatte möchte ich ihnen eine frage
stellen waren sie schon mal bei einer
jahreshauptversammlung einer
wohnungsbaugenossenschaft
stellt sich eine turnhalle oder ein
bürgerhaus vor gefüllt mit menschen aus
ihrer nachbarschaft da treffen sie immer
auch ein paar von den lokalen
würdenträgern zu über die sie mal nennen
die bürgermeisterin heldentums wort und
dann wird zwischen apfelschorle und
alkoholfreie weizen über das
zusammenleben diskutiert es wird
demokratisch abgestimmt es wird
solidarisch entschieden
baugenossenschaften stehen für
selbsthilfe für selbstverwaltung und für
solidarität
2,9 millionen menschen in deutschland
sind mitglied einer baugenossenschaft
auch ich gehöre dazu
unter ihrer aufsicht entsteht gute
wohnraum wohnungen die barrierefrei sind
die vermehre generationen für kleine
oder auch für große familien mit vielen
kindern geeignet sind aus meiner
persönlichen erfahrung weiß ich hier
wird nicht mit wohnraum spekuliert hier
wird gekümmert
das schafft langfristige wohnung
sicherheit und ermöglicht bezahlbaren
wohnraum wohnraum den wir so dringend
brauchen heute
häufig sind baugenossenschaften außerdem
wichtige partner der kommunen bei der
planung und entwicklung von quartieren
unterstützen sie mit expertise und
beteiligen sich an der umsetzung
sie werden wohl unfälle auf und flink
infrastrukturen aus persönlichen
gesprächen in meiner heimatregion im
kreis groß gerau und von gerichten auf
den besagten jahreshauptversammlung weiß
ich dass sowohl die mitglieder als auch
die angestellten der genossenschaften
eine nicht zu unterschätzende soziale
aufgabe übernehmen dank des ausgeprägten
gemeinschaft sind schaut man
nacheinander wer braucht vielleicht
hilfe wer hat schwierigkeiten die
treppen zu steigen dazu kommen viele
weitere soziale dienstleistungen die
gerne auch von älteren mieterinnen und
mietern angenommen werden was für eine
tolle sache danke an alle die das
möglich macht
etwa fünf millionen menschen wohnen
deutschlandweit in einer
genossenschaftswohnung und es dürfen
gerne mehr werden deswegen nehmen wir
auch dieses jahr mit dem haushalt 20 22
zusätzliches geld in die hand zur
förderung von genossenschaftlichen
wohnungen damit mehr leute in den genuss
einer genossenschaftswohnung kommen
können denn im gegensatz zum bauminister
der letzten legislatur der dieses
vorhaben immer wieder geschoben hat und
mehr letztlich ist nichts passiert setzt
die neue ministerin dieses vorhaben mit
einer forderung von einem euro direkt um
dafür war
darüber freue ich mich als neue
genossenschafts beauftragte meiner
fraktion ganz besonderes denn es ist ein
wichtiger baustein auf unserem
gemeinsamen ziel auf dem weg jährlich
400.000 mal wohnungen zu schaffen und es
ist ein wichtiger baustein für den
sozialen wohnungsbau für junge
wohnkonzepte und auch für studenten und
azubis auf dass die
jahreshauptversammlung zukünftig noch
geselliger werden und für die marke von
drei millionen mitgliedern bald knacken
vielen dank
[Applaus]
weitere wortmeldungen zu diesem
einzelplan liegen nicht vor